New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio will
travel to Iowa and South Carolina after
announcing his run for the presidency
this morning as president I will take on
the wealthy I will take on the big
corporations I will not rest until this
government serves working people de
Blasio is the 24th candidate and third
mayor to enter the race for the
Democratic nomination ed O'Keefe is
covering the 2020 campaign Edie good
morning good morning Bill DeBlasio is
the answer to what question that isn't
being unclear I love god bless the New
York Post this morning
New Yorkers laughing on the cover this
is probably better I think the problem
is he thinks if you can make it here you
can make it anywhere but what if you
make it polling but here's the thing
polling shows yes yeah national
Democrats would prefer he maintained a
New York state of mind with apologies to
Frank Sinatra and Billy Joel look he
like all these other Democrats seems to
think there is something he can
contribute to this conversation
he already this morning touting the
universal pre-k program that he's
established here in New York the fact
that they're pushing for environmental
protections that you know up against
someone like Steve Bullock just
yesterday antenna saying that you know
look at my more moderate record we have
to talk to states in the middle of the
country each of them believes they've
got some compelling argument that could
somehow help them prevent the field may
continue to grow Stacey Abrams still
looking at that what does make it stop
what's the practical effect I mean in
some ways does this strength and Biden's
hand yes that's all of them will divide
the anti by denote and this is this is
this is the interesting dynamic that I
don't think they anticipated his numbers
have only improved if you look at
numbers were actually in South Carolina
now where he's leading by 33 points in
one survey he's got a commanding lead
over the President hypothetically in a
Pennsylvania matchup all of these guys
are just continuing to bolster him and
Bernie Sanders to some extent leaving
open the possibility that maybe one of
them somehow breaks out of the pack
later on but it's so it's alternate so
they all divide the vote and then Biden
stays at the top which is not unlike
what happened to Donald Trump exactly
last race but there is also the other
option which is that everybody decides
to go after Joe Biden we saw Camilla
Harris saying that the crime bill that
Joe Biden was so much in support of in
the 90s did in fact lead to mass
incarceration which felt like the first
kind of serious knock on him from a
fellow candidate do you expect more of
that and how serious do you think come
lahars at this point I think looking at
how he has held up over the last few
weeks they don't have a choice but to go
after him now at least in some way
whether it's the crime bill whether is
some liberals this week have gone after
him on his environmental record whether
it's some other aspect of the work he
did as a senator with the Obama
administration it's starting to happen
it will happen he's anticipating it and
will be interesting to see whether it
does anything to bring him down to earth
but with 24 candidates is there such a
thing as too many candidates I read an
article in The New York Times recently
that said it's never bad to be able to
say behind your name former presidential
candidate that's part of it for some of
these people but look I think the guys
in the graphics department would tell
you that this is too many because you
can barely see their faces and when you
look at the 24 without naming names
realistically who do you think really
has no shot we if you'd asked me that
four years ago people would have said
Donald Trump right yeah now he's
president yeah we say but he had other
things going for he did he did yeah
Universal named American none of these
guys with the exception of maybe Biden
and Sanders can say that they have name
recognition that holds up in quite the
Simon I'm always curious are we fall
into stereotypes and describing people
in politics particularly that's six
women who are running for president
senator Kamala Harris was asked talked
about the other day whether she's sick
of talk about how she would be the
perfect running mate here's how she
responded listen I think that Joe Biden
would be a great running mate as vice
president he's proven that he knows how
to do the job is it or most of these
women being judged unfairly as potential
running mates rather than as primary
well there's on the ticket first of all
that's what we call the definition of a
clap back yeah very good move on her
part you know it's a question that's
been asked of the men and I think she's
spinning it there to say wait a second
why aren't you asking us whether we
would pick a guy yeah so there is
perhaps something to that
six of them they're all you know
perfectly qualified people who very well
could emerge as the nominee any of these
well most of these guys could
potentially emerges the nominee well the
more people that get in what did your
dad tell you ensure its full employment
for you yeah yeah that's right about
that